before i jump into tom and jerry i just
want to uh for people that have never
seen shadow in the cloud
um i think i just want to give a shout
out to that film and how good you were
in it and i think people should
make an effort to see it thank you very
much i i feel i
did shadow in the cloud right before tom
and jerry which are probably the most
polar opposite films you could ever do
back to back a hundred percent
um one of the things i think that's uh
with tom and jerry is that
uh it's everything had to be pre like uh
storyboarded and figured out
you know when you're on set and it's
very exact i'm just curious how many
like takes were ruined
because you moved one inch past your
mark
you know we were we were kind of lucky
you know there was
exact measurements and movement and the
biggest thing was really eye line
um but outside of that the animators
were always on set
so they would immediately run in after a
take if i had
done anything or anything like that
where we would have to change a certain
thing
but there was more freedom than i
expected going into it and
really the answer was the further i went
and the bigger i went with their
kind of responses their miming in my
mind with that improv
they could animate further so they kind
of wanted me to push that boundary
but you know at the same time give me my
ramifications of distance
did you have new respect for what
zemeckis
uh pulled off on roger rabbit after
making this film
oh of course i mean i i rodriguez one of
my favorite films growing up and you
know bob haskins i've read his
interviews after the fact and how he
said he he went a little bit crazy after
that movie after having talked to
himself for so many months on end and i
i kind of you know i i don't disagree
with him i did feel
a little nuts by the end of it but it is
such an enlivening
wild experience and it is such a a brain
teaser you know i worked so intimately
with tim's story
on this to really make it work and to
figure out
what we needed how to do it and you know
my first questions were all those
those things that i just stated to him
and he you know his answer was like
honestly
i don't know and that's the excitement
of this project which is we got to kind
of go in there and figure out
what the hell we're going to do so that
was a
fun and scary and exciting experience
michael pena always makes me laugh
and uh i would imagine uh working with
him
had there was there had to have been a
lot of laughter working with him i'm
just curious how many takes did he was
he purposely trying to make you break
i mean you know half the time we would
both look at each other and be like
what are we doing you know because we
would just be upping the ante on each
other
and he'd be going bigger and i'd be
going bigger and then he'd be going
bigger
and then he's like you know grabbing at
my jacket in that scene with the mouse
in my pocket
and you know we would just look at each
other like what are we filming
so we had a lot of fun uh teasing each
other and going down that path
watching tom and jerry cartoons as an
adult and even this movie
you're kind of blown away by the level
of violence they inflict
on each other um and it's very rare to
like like
it's it's pretty crazy can you sort of
talk about that that they literally
do everything they can to each other the
violence is pretty crazy
it is pretty wild i mean i i do really
appreciate that
you know they really stuck by the
original cartoon and they didn't change
much of that from the 81 years of this
cartoon running
um and i thought that was that was
really something to be said you know
that they that they
kind of went the extra mile with all the
crazy hijinks of
dropping hammers on each other's heads
and you know spiky baseball bats and
all the crazy things that really ensue
on screen so
it is pretty wild and it is pretty
jarring but it's the classic characters
that we love so much and i think if they
hadn't had done that i think we would
have been more upset
than than not you know completely i
already got to go i'm just going to say
congrats
uh i wish you nothing but the best and
good luck with your speed dating
nah thank you so much that is totally
speed dating see you later